[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday February
22nd and this is the sound of my MacBook
makes when I've got the speakers on
while I'm recording well mom well that's
that's enough for that yesterday a
commenter julia brought up a problem
that i think a lot of us deal with now
because you're a semi-famous author i
think that a large percentage of our fan
base are book readers problem with
ebooks is that the kind of big I mean
that one book but when you have a couple
hundred they can become kind of unwieldy
and it can become kind of difficult to
find places to put all of them I have
this problem and so does Julia and I
would like to show Julia and the rest of
our viewers how I deal with this problem
we have this bookshelf which anonymous
books but also DVDs and some random
stuff and my books and my best it looks
as if these are just affixed to the wall
as if there's some kind of anti-gravity
device
how does work those things sticking them
off it's got a little clasp down there
put it on and I hold up the cover
over here we have a less innovative
method for storing books another method
of storing books is to put embarrassing
books in the closet what what Star Trek
novels I don't have a Star Trek novel up
here we have two more of the amazing
floating book stacks they also double
nicely as picture holders Katherine and
I are also friends of the random stacks
and random places this one is on our
kitchen table so yeah we have a lot of
built-in shelving which helps us with
the book problem more random stacks and
random places
oh there's my underwear drawer mm-hmm
this one is on our dresser then of
course there is the bed stand stack
which you will notice includes Phillip
gaurav itches we wish to inform you that
tomorrow we will be killed with our
families these are the books that
supposedly we are reading right now so I
have to say that I haven't been reading
that book very much lately sometimes we
find books in completely random places
like on top of this bowl poor let's side
magazine stack another end of stack my
chemistry books are hiding find pictures
of Italy and the three-volume complete
Calvin and Hobbes but most importantly
we have the places where the books go
when we can't fit any more books because
we will always have this problem the
place the Covenant I almost commonly go
is called the book exchange the book
exchange is awesome because you can buy
books from the book exchange and then
exchange them for the exact amount that
you paid for them so say the Catherine
bought an Agatha Christie book from the
book exchange for a dollar fifty she can
take it back and get a dollar fifty and
use paperback credit
just today Katherine and I took back a
giant stack of books to the book
exchange where they gave us $40 so that
we could buy more books at the book
exchange this is a pretty good deal
because they had a lot more shelf space
than we do and it's a heck of a lot
cheaper than buying books Barnes and
Noble how to authors feel about used
bookstores other authors here are of
course invited to answer this question
as well what about libraries and what
about downloaded books I mean I
personally have to admit that I have in
fact downloaded books before and read
them on the Internet
I really feel bad about it because
they're not the kind of books for the
authors are really trying to make a
living like Alexander Duma he's not
saying
oh I wish those people wouldn't download
my books the question becomes when we
buy a book what are we paying for in all
these cases libraries use bookstores and
downloaded books people are reading your
books but you're not getting credit for
it
you're not getting money for it so how
does that make you feel one thing I know
for sure is that it'd be a heck of a lot
easier to put all these books someplace
if they were on my hard drive instead of
on my wall I'll see you tomorrow